foreign
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
very much welcome to the chamber and you
are kindly requested to take your seats
the 19 plenary meeting of the 11th
emergency special session of the general
assembly is called to order
before proceeding further I would like
to remind members that all meeting
participants are encouraged to consider
wearing a mask while indoors including
indigen Assembly Hall and in conference
rooms
the general assembly will continue its
consideration of agent item 5.
we shall now proceed to consider drought
resolution a slash es 11 L7
and draft amendments a slash es 11 L8
and a slash ES
eleven slash L9
before proceeding further I would like
to inform members that the draft
resolution and draft Amendments have
closed for e-sponsorship I now give the
floor to the representative of the
secretary
Mr President I will address the
additional co-sponsorship or for all
three L documents fast L4 L7 I should
like to announce that since the
submission of the draft resolution and
in addition to the delegations listed on
the L document the foreign countries
have also become co-sponsors of a slash
es11 L7
Antiguan babuda
peris
carvelde
Dominican Republic
Ecuador
Jamaica
Myanmar Nigel
Papua New Guinea
Peru
Samoa
Singapore
Suriname
Tonga
Trinidad and Tobago Uruguay and vanvatu
if any other countries wish to call
sponsor a slash es11 L7 please signify
by pressing the microphone button
I see none
next I will go to L8 I should like to
announce that since the submission of
the draft amendment in an in addition to
the delegations listed on the L document
the foreign country
has also become co-sponsor of a es11 L8
Nicaragua
if any other countries wish to
corresponse a slash es11 L8 please
signify by pressing the microphone
button
none
finally for L9 since the submission of
the draft Amendment and in addition to
the delegation listed on the L document
the foreign country has also become
co-sponsor of a slash es11 L9
Nicaragua
if any other countries wish to
co-sponsor a slash es11 a09
pre-signify by pressing the microphone
button now
I see none thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
here of the Secretariat
delegations wishing to make a statement
in explanation of votes before the vote
on any of the proposals under this item
including proposed amendments are
invited to do so now
in one intervention
before giving the floor for
explanational vote before the vote
may I remind delegations that
explanation of vote are limited to 10
minutes and should be made by
delegations from their seats
I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Djibouti
thank you president
we
would have liked today's vote to be on a
resolution celebrating the end of a war
and the beginning of lasting peace
quite the country we are seeing a
continued deterioration in the security
situation
an intensification of conflict and
violence which is becoming ever more
brutal given the war like rhetoric we
are hearing this scenario is further
darkened by the threat of the use of
nuclear weapons and the probability of
nuclear accidents we were shocked and
bewildered regarding the reasons behind
the wall
and a year on we are still confused
about the reasons for the for its
continuation without a clear perspective
for an exit to the crisis either through
direct negotiation or remediation of a
third party
peace has become a controversial notion
and colored by suspicions
during this extraordinary session today
our resolution aims to clarify the way
to reach at just lasting and
comprehensive piece and this deserves
our support despite these Dark Horizons
we must never abandon
we must work tirelessly to promote just
and Lasting peace upon the basis of the
United Nations Charter and international
law
violence
must give way to dialogue and diplomacy
International Peace and security can
only be achieved by the compliance of
all states with their obligations under
the UN Charter
Thief among these are the obligations to
respect the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
other states as inscribed in article 2-4
and to refrain from the threat or use of
force Wars of aggression cannot be
tolerated
nor can efforts to acquire author
territory or change borders by Force of
Arms
all such fragrant video violations of
basic International Norms must be called
out denounced resisted and opposed by
all law-abiding States
Djibouti did it one year ago and we are
doing it again today
there can be no fatigue when it comes to
violations of the charter and and other
fundamental breaches of the
international order this is the reason
why Djibouti will vote in favor in favor
of the draft resolution before us today
thank you for your attention
thank the distinguished representative
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Nigeria
the president
the global Community has a recent in the
recent past and do what many disasters
the most accurate ones being in the
Ukraine Pakistan turkey and Syria the
causes and remedies vary yet all have
been accompanied by loss of thousands of
lives properties and displacement many
countries entities individuals have
stepped up in support of human beings
who found themselves in these conditions
this is the kind of Trilogy the United
Nations advocates for provides and
organizes Nigeria continues to express
concerns over the ongoing war against
Ukraine and regrets the inability of the
International Community to broker peace
between the Russian Federation and
Ukraine both of whom are members of this
assembly
the Unitarian crisis is worsening and
cities and towns in Ukraine are being
destroyed even Beyond Ukraine hardly can
we point a country unaffected by the
consequences of the war Nigeria is
committed to the purposes and principles
of the United Nations Charter and
international law it it upholds
violation of the uncharter despite
continuation of aggression against
Ukraine Mr President members with this
organization must prioritize and win
this war thereafter working towards
sustainable feed the Russian Federation
and Ukraine Nigeria commands efforts of
the Secretary General and the Republic
of UK in history ensuring supplies of
Grants to countries that needed them
most and ensuring military and access
we should deepen this approach by
focusing on stopping the preventing
further loss of life and destruction of
towns and cities causing terrible
displacement countries and entities that
have influenced on the two countries
need to work with the United Nations to
achieve this objective we all have some
responsibility in this
it is Nigeria's firm belief that the
cause of peace in our world will be
eminently enhanced if among other things
we overcome the will to invade and
occupy and the tendency to assume it
right that some countries are merely
security zones or zones of control by
others
has guided us for so long even with some
of his social structural limitations of
all the elements of the charter of our
organization the most important ones are
the principles of respect for subology
of states and the principle of peaceful
settlement of disputes
while Nigeria strongly believes
in the need
to hold all parties accountable for the
crimes committed
we register our reservation about op9 of
the tax
in the draft L7
principles of the charter of the United
Nations underline a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine the most
urgent accountability is for us to see
whatever resources other than violence
at our disposal we can use whatever
resources at a disposal to guarantee
that this was tropes Nigeria will not is
not fully sure that op9 is really
helpful in stopping the war it may
Harden positions and may get a solution
more difficult in addition not only the
mechanism for the investigation and
prosecution is unclear in the tax is
also not difficult to see how the
assembly will be broke down for years to
come over which aggressions by some
member states should be treated in the
same manner or which ones should be
prioritized
it is in light of these and other
considerations the Nigeria will vote in
favor of the resolution but the reserve
on on Pro Group nine we may well decide
at an appropriate time to have a focused
honest if difficult discussion about
accountability in all cases of United
action occupation and settlement against
sovereign states with a determination to
make this end and Achieve genuine
reconciliation the solarities that we
have seen in giving Comfort to victims
in Ukraine turkey Syria and Pakistan
recently should give us hope that this
is both necessary and possible in
conclusion Mr President in line with the
Church of the United Nations and
especially concerning the invaluability
of borders and peaceful settlement of
disputes in Nigeria
will vote on the conclusion while
designing op9 Nigeria affirms what we
all signed onto and looking at the
consequences of doing Ukraine on
ukrainians on the rest of the world
I just focused attention first of the
association although I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Nigeria
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Nepal
thank you Mr President Mr President
my delegation is deeply distressed by a
year-long conflict
death and Devastation in Ukraine
it has posed an extreme danger to
International Peace and security
Untold our sorrows and ramifications of
the conflict
be death and Devastation in Ukraine
disruption of global supply chain food
insecurity and inflation worldwide
peaceful coexistence
mutual respect for sovereignty
cater to your integrity and
non-aggression as enshrined in the
United Nations Charter are the
fundamentals of Nepal's foreign policy
the United Nations started unequivocally
stipulates that all member states shall
refrain and their international
relations
from the threat or user Force against
the international against the territory
integrity
or political independence of any state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the purpose of the United Nations
further the charter says all members
shall settle their international
disputes by peaceful means in such a
manner that International Peace and
security and Justice are not in danger
Mr President
security and stability of one and all
countries are founded on these very
principles
Nepal's position has been clear from the
very beginning of this conflict based on
the foundation of U.N Charter and
international law
Nepal had astute for the sovereignty and
territory Integrity of Ukraine and the
protection of its civilians
Nepal has clearly pronounced that no
solution can arrive through hostilities
and conflict
Mr President as provided by the United
Nations Charter dialogue and diplomacy
are the tools for resolving disputes and
differences
as a peace-loving country Nepal
reiterates its call for the immediate
cessation of hostilities and the
creation of conditions for dialect and
diplomacy
and we urge all the efforts by the
parties in Conflict as well as the
International Community should be
channelized to create conditions for
peace
the draft resolution and just peace in
Ukraine is before us today
the draft could
articulated
the Primacy of negotiation and dialogue
and created a condition of just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine which we
believe is the fundamental for
achievement of the durable peace in
Ukraine
nevertheless we believe the draft
resolution is intended to protect the
sovereignty territorial integrity and
Independence of Ukraine and bring peace
in Ukraine
in this context
with a firm belief in U.N Charter and
settlement of international disputes
through peaceful means
my delegation will support the draft
resolution that is before us thank you
Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Nepal
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of South Africa
Mr President
South Africa continues to express its
deep regret that the war in Ukraine
which tomorrow marks its first
anniversary
continues to destroy innocent lives and
critical infrastructure
as well as the displacing Millions
this is a war whose impact has resonated
across the globe
affecting the livelihoods of the most
vulnerable
and heightening the current debilitating
Global Food Fuel and finance crisis
wishes to stress it's unwavering belief
in the purposes and principles of the
U.N Charter
we believe that sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of all states
should be sacrosanct
and this also applies to Ukraine
Mr President we also
affirm in a resolve that urgent actions
are needed to end the war
however it is a certain document of our
efforts that we as the International
Community have been unable to come up
with concrete proposals
to create the conditions to do so
as South Africa has stated before in
this assembly
diplomacy and dialogue is the only path
that will lead to a sustainable and
peaceful resolution of the conflict
today we consider yet another resolution
on the war in Ukraine
which comes amidst an influx of arms to
the region perpetuating greater acts of
violence and increased human suffering
this together with the thread of nuclear
war
makes peace seem less attainable
over the last year this assembly has
adopted a series of resolutions on
Ukraine
as we have asked this assembly before
our ways and actions focus on the
maintenance of peace
or creating further divisions that make
the attainment of immediate peace less
likely
while we support the present resolutions
focus on the principles of the charter
and international law
sadly brings us no closer to lean the
foundations
for a durable peace and bringing an end
to the devastation and destruction
what we need is a femme
and equivocal commitment to peace from
all parties I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of South Africa
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Thailand
Mr President
Thailand reiterates our unequivocal
adherence to the U.N Charter both in
letter and spirit as well as to
international law as the non-arbitrary
point of reference for standards of
conduct of Nations
Thailand upholds the people's rights to
live in safety
with their basic well-being as universal
and non-negotiable
humanitarian consideration must not be
politicized and discriminatory
we urge the United Nations to dispense
its best and most Earnest effort in
preventive diplomacy to safeguard these
basic human rights around the world and
not to become a part of the morality
play that turns very complex situations
into simple binaries of Good and Evil
followed by finger-pointing and
condemnations
utmost efforts should be carried out to
create conducive environments for
engagement and dialogues to settle
disputes once they erupt rather than
adding fuel to the fire
the Hippocratic Oath should apply in all
the UN Endeavors quote First Do no harm
unquote
on the one year anniversary of war in
Ukraine we urge all members of this
prestigious body to do the right thing
by The World At Large and by the 8
billion people who are simply bystanders
but are bearing the brunt of the war in
very many different ways
for the peace settlement process to
start we must try to understand the root
causes of the conflict in an objective
and non-miopic manner devoid of the
power and morality Play Elements
the world is vast and Rich enough for
countries with diverse ideologies and
political form of government to coexist
peacefully if we learn to respect the
differences and heed our respective
existential
more weapons escalate fighting more
fighting worse since human suffering
more sanctions intensify human pain and
have never led to regime change
condemnations bear no positive weight on
altering Behavior or conducts
Thailand calls on all parties to step up
the Diplomatic effort to engage in
dialogues to achieve a peaceful
negotiated settlement as an exit to the
Ukraine conflict
the war in Ukraine represents an
unprecedented and most dangerous
challenge that threatens the
geopolitical financial Economic Security
and Collective balance of the World At
Large
it was said diplomacy is the
continuation of War by other means
Wars cannot be settled by deployment of
more lethal weapons not unless total
Destruction and human casualties are the
only objectives and the only option
available
Wars can only be settled by engagements
and dialogues by pragmatism not ideology
and not by the winner take all mindset
as in Isaiah 1 18
it is now time for all nations to come
and quote reason together unquote thank
you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Thailand
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Angola
thank you Mr President excellences the
resolution that we are about to adopt is
being discussed at the time when the
conflict in Ukraine over a period of
more than 12 months as claimed in a
calculable human lives and caused
multiple doses of material Goods we
consider document a slash es slash 11
slash l.7 to be progressed in view of
the fact that International Community is
showing clear signs of support for the
process of seeking a peaceful solution
to the conflict and the making efforts
to bring the parties closer together for
a lasting peace in Eastern Europe region
on the other end as United Nations
General Assembly is the most
representative body of our organization
we think it is important that the
intergovernmental process is inclusive
it is therefore imperative that the
documents as everyone's contribution and
raising it so that we can have Ukraine
and Russia coexisting peacefully a more
stable and strong region
and an increasingly peaceful words
Angola will abstain during the vote
we are of the opinion that operative
paragraph line is not conducive to
creating an environment conducive to the
start of peaceful negotiations
we do not see difficulties with the
other paragraphs Republic of Angola
defends the notion of accountability of
crimes committed by any of the parties
however we do not think this is the
right time to have a paragraph in the
resolution
and not to undermine the Secretary
General efforts and initiatives to
promote a lasting and comprehensive
peace between the two countries
excellencies
we would like to reiterate that Republic
of Angola is on opinion that the
conflict resolution between Russia and
Ukraine
can only be resolved through dialogue
and therefore the general assembly of
United Nations must maintain its
interest in preserving the principles of
peaceful coexistence
among member states I thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Angola
now I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of Brazil
thank you Mr President
Mr President
Brazil has decided to vote in favor of
the draft resolution before us
because of the urgent need
for this General Assembly to reaffirm
its unwavering commitment to uphold the
core principles of the U.N Charter and
international law
while underscoring the need to reach
peace
we commend the facilitators for the
inclusive negotiations
in our view the most important element
of the resolution
is the call for the International
Community to redouble its efforts to
achieve a just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
we also appreciate the important
humanitarian element of the resolution
including the call for full adherence of
all parties to their obligations under
International humanitarian law
all possible measures must be adopted to
minimize the suffering of the civilian
population
it is high time to start peace talks
rather than fuel the conflict
Brazil considers the call for the
cessation of hostilities in op5
as an appeal to both sides to Halt
violence without preconditions
no alleged difficulties to implement our
call to stop hostilities as as set forth
in this paragraph must be seen as an
obstacle to start negotiations
this resolution must be construed as an
important step to pave the way for peace
the conflict that started a year ago has
imposed immense suffering on civilians
it also entailed a number of
consequences for many countries
especially in the developing World due
to its impacts on food fertilizer and
energy prices
the time has come
to open space for dialogue and to begin
reconstruction Brazil stands ready to
participate in the efforts for a lasting
solution to this conflict I thank you Mr
President
Brazil
now I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of Malaysia
Mr President
Malaysia has been following closely the
ongoing conflict in Ukraine
we are deeply concerned over the
increase in civilian casualties and in
the number of displaced persons as well
as the destruction of Civilian
infrastructure which continues to this
day
in any armed conflict it is always the
affected civilians men women young and
old who suffer the most as such we urge
all parties to fully comply with their
obligations under International
humanitarian law and international human
rights law
at the same time Malaysia wishes to see
an immediate end to hostilities and the
start of peaceful negotiations
Malaysia believes that for Meaningful
dialogue and negotiations to start all
sides must stick into consideration the
legitimate security concerns of both
Ukraine and Russia given the complex
geopolitical context
this must be addressed through dialogue
and peaceful means in accordance with
the principles of the UN Charter and the
rule of law
Malaysia has and will continue to uphold
the principles of respect for the
sovereignty and the independence and
territorial Integrity of states
staying faithful to these principles
Malaysia will vote in favor of this
resolution
Mr President
Malaysia regrets what we see as the
inability or unwillingness of the
security Council to discharge its
primary responsibility to maintain
International Peace and security
the general assembly has adopted six
resolutions related to the ongoing
conflict but the situation on the ground
Remains the Same if not worse
in this regard Malaysia calls on all
parties concern to take immediate steps
to de-escalate to prevent further loss
of lives and destruction
today we have heard calls and appeals
for a comprehensive just and Lasting
Peace by fellow delegates malicious
strongly Echo these calls and appeals
Mr President finally Malaysia wishes to
register our disappointment over the
fact that there were no open-ended
discussions with member states at Large
we feel that there should be more
open-ended consultations so that the
larger membership of the UN would be
able to engage with the pen holders in
order to add their views especially
since this is the sixth resolution on
the issue
Malaysia Retreats our commitment to the
peaceful settlement of disputes Guided
by the principles and Shrine in the UN
Charter and under international law in
the interest of maintaining Regional and
International Peace and security I thank
you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Malaysia
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the United Kingdom
thank you Mr President I will be brief
before we vote on the main resolution
allow me to address the Amendments
proposed by Belarus
they have been put forward by a state
that has facilitated Russia's invasion
that provided the staging ground for the
early attempt to cop to topple Kiev
and that is among a small number of
states that have consistently voted
against upholding Ukraine's rights under
the UN Charter
the amendments attempt to create a false
equivalence between Russia
which this general assembly and the
Secretary General have made clear is
engaged in a full-scale invasion
and Ukraine
which is exercising Its Right of
self-defense against that aggression
put simply
these amendments are an attempt to
undermine the charter
they're not aimed at peace
but at defending the aggressor
they are not proposed in good faith
so we urge member states to vote against
these amendments so we can move to vote
in favor of the resolution that
genuinely seeks a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the UN Charter and I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of the United Kingdom
expenses We Have Heard the Last speaker
in explanation of vote before the vote
I wish to address the question
concerning the majority required for the
adoption of the draft resolution
in light of article 18 paragraphs 2 and
3 of the charter of the United Nations
is there any is there any objection to
taking action on draft resolution a
slash ES
L7 by 2 3 majority of the members
present and voting
I see none
the two-thirds majority of member State
members present and voting is therefore
required for the adoption of the draft
resolution a slash es 11 L7
[Music]
the two-thirds majority of members
present and voting is therefore also
required for the adoption of the draft
amendments
a slash es11 L8 and a slash es 11 L9
before proceeding to take a decision on
draft resolution a slash es 11
L7 in accordance with the rule 90 of the
user procedure the assembly shall first
take a decision on draft amendments a
slash es11 L8 and a slash es 11 L9 one
by one
we first turn to draft a draft Amendment
a slash es 11 LH
a recorded vote has been requested on
draft Amendment a slash ES
11 L8
we shall now begin the voting process
those in favor of draft amendments a
slash es 11 L8 please signify those
against or abstentions
assembly is now voting on draft
Amendment a slash es11
L8 L8
will all delegations confirm that the
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has been completed
please lock the machine
the results of the voters as follows in
favor eleven
against
abstentions 56.
draft Amendment a slash es 11 L8 is not
adopted
we turn next to draft Amendment a slash
es11 L9
a recorded vote has been requested on
draft Amendment a slash es11 L9 we shall
now begin the voting process
those in favor of draft Amendment a
slash es 11 L9 please signify those
against or abstentions the general
assembly is now voting on draft
Amendment a slash es11 L9 L9
where all delegations confirm that the
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has been completed please
lock the machine
the result of the vote is as follows
in favor
15.
against 91.
abstentions 52 draft Amendment a slash
es 11 L9 is not adopted
since draft amendments a slash es11 L8
and a slash es11 L9 were not adopted we
shall proceed to take a decision on
their draft resolution as a slash es 11
L7
the assembly will now take a decision on
draft resolution a slash es 11
L7 entitled I quote
principles of the charter of the United
Nations underlining a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine end of
quote
a recorded vote has been requested we
shall now begin the voting process those
in favor of draft resolution a slash
es11 L7 please signify those against or
abstentions the general assembly is now
voting on draft resolution a slash es 11
L7 L7 entitled principles of the charter
of the United Nations underlying a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
will all delegations confirm that the
votes are accurately deflected on the
screen
being completed
the result
against
Dimensions 32
draft resolution a slash es11 L7 is
adopted
[Laughter]
before giving the floor to explanation
of vote after the vote May I remind
delegations that explanation of vote are
limited to 10 minutes and shall be made
by delegations from the essays
now I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of Cuba
president
pursuant to our strong commitment to the
Charter of the United Nations and
international law Cuba defends the
independence
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
states and self-determination of peoples
we oppose absolutely the threat or use
of force
and support the peaceful resolution of
conflicts and disputes
almost a year ago
before this General Assembly we warned
that history would call for
responsibility from the government of
the United States for the consequences
of a military Doctrine which is
increasingly offensive in nature
outside NATO borders and which threatens
peace security and stability
internationally in Ukraine today rather
than tensions decreasing the
confrontation is exacerbating on the
ground through the increasing movement
of weapons aggressive rhetoric and
unilateral sanctions which contribute to
extending the conflict Cuba abstained
on the vote of on draft resolution L7
deeming it not to contribute to dialogue
or be propitious to dialogue or
negotiation with the participation of
all parties involved
to reach true and Lasting peace
achieving that objective is urgent today
we cannot continue to stoke a conflict
which every day causes Dead deaths and
wounded people and material damage we
reject any attempts in the future to
manipulate this text as a legal basis to
justify the possible creation of
tribunals aimed at carrying out
judgments at National or International
level the general assembly
has no mandate for that
Cuba will continue to tirelessly
advocate for a diplomatic solution which
is constructive serious and realistic to
the current crisis in Ukraine through
peaceful means
and
under international law which guarantees
the security and sovereignty of all as
well as peace and security on a regional
and international level thank you very
much I thank the distinguished
representative of Cuba before giving the
fraud to the next speaker may I kindly
ask delegates
to tone down their conversations
let's pay respect to all speakers
equally
thank you very much for your
understanding
now I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of Egypt
thank you Mr President we thank you for
trying to reinstate order in the hall
sir sir Egypt has voted in favor of the
draft resolution submitted to the
general assembly within its firm
commitment to the purposes and
principles of the United Nations Charter
especially in terms of the peaceful
settlement of international disputes and
respect for the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of member states
this is resolutely reflected in Egypt's
foreign positions
with regards to all the international
resolutions
here Egypt would like to confirm the
following
first
today's vote coincides with the one year
anniversary of the outbreak of the
crisis in Ukraine whose repercussions be
the humanitarian or economic have
affected everyone and not simply the
warring factions
developing countries especially
including Egypt suffer directly
because of the continuation of this
crisis
a crisis
that has affected
the economies of developing States
severely as a result of the negative
impact it's had on food security and
energy security and its disruption of
Supply chains
unfortunately Mr President the
International Community continues to be
lacks in addressing the economic and
social challenges posed by this crisis
two developing countries
it is also unfortunate that
International Community has been lacks
in working together to arrive at an
appropriate solution to the crisis
Egypt reaffirms the need to work
immediately on resolving the Ukrainian
crisis and we would like to remind those
in attendance of the genuine call that
was made by Egyptian president
at the inauguration session of the cop
27 conference on climate change in
Charleston where he called for the need
to end the Ukrainian war and look for
means to settle it
Egypt had hoped that the resolution
adopted today would have proposed
mechanisms to resolve the crisis and to
launch a series of comprehensive
negotiations with no preconditions to
resolve this crisis Egypt would like to
urge all relevant International parties
to actively search for the appropriate
mechanism to
expeditiously resume negotiations in a
manner that would address the root of
the crisis and would guarantee a
response to the security concerns of all
warring parties and would guarantee
their National Security in an equal and
fair and sustainable manner
Egypt urges all parties be they involved
directly or indirectly in the crisis to
cease any escalation and to refrain from
taking any measures that would prolong
the crisis or exacerbate it
this aims to stop the Bloodshed and the
human suffering in the zone of conflict
and would end the humanitarian impact of
the crisis that has affected innocence
and continents that are thousands of
miles away from this conflict
in closing Mr President each tops
that this current crisis would serve as
a reminder to everyone internationally
of the need to stop dealing
or stop using dual standards and double
standards in dealing with similar
situations in accordance with
international law because the use of
such double standards would only lead to
the erosion international law and would
topple the international
structure and its entirety thank you
representative of Egypt
South Sudan
Mr President so Sudan takes the floor in
explanation of vote after the vote
sorceron voted in favor of the
resolution just adopted
since the Inception of the conflict a
year ago
so Sudan has maintained and continued
continuously cast an abstained vote
as a country that emerged from the
longest Civil War in the country in the
continent
and is implementing a peace agreement
which many of you in this chamber helped
to deliver
We join
we joined to vote in favor of the draft
with the singular reason that this
conflict needs to stop
its Devastation has been experienced far
and widely
therefore
through our vote we strongly call for a
peaceful and Speedy settlement
through a negotiated mechanism agreed
upon by the parties to the conflict
is our considered belief that there is
no military solution to the conflict
then the destruction we have witnessed I
thank you Mr President
South Sudan
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Indonesia
Mr President
one year after the War Began in Ukraine
we are no closer to peace
death suffering and destruction
continues to mount
the impact of the war has gone beyond
the borders of the countries in
conflicts
Indonesia voted in favor for the
resolution because we believe upholding
the principle of the U.N Charter and
international law
including peaceful resolution of dispute
respect for human rights
and the rule of law are fundamental to
resolve the ongoing conflict in Ukraine
despite this we deeply regret that
critical Elements which we
constructively suggested in the drafting
process are missing in the final draft
in this regard we believe the resolution
adopted today may not have achieved the
intended goal which is to help bring the
countries at War closer to peace
the resolution is missing the spirit to
realizing peace in Ukraine
nor does the resolution call on the
International Community to create
condition conducive to ending the war
most notably the resolution is missing
the call for the two parties in Conflict
to pursue dialogue diplomatic means and
enter into direct peace negotiation
ultimately to two parties themselves are
the ones that can and must prevent
further downward spiral and end the war
we are also concerned that the
resolution failed to avoid a zero-sum
game approach to resolving the
underlying problem
as such
approach will only deepen The Divide
between the conflicting parties
Mr President
the general assembly is the most
inclusive organ of the United Nations
its resolution reflects the collective
voice and statement of 193 members of
the United Nation
it is therefore fundamental that its
resolution be factually correct accurate
inclusive and balanced
GA resolutions are not social media
content
The credibility of our August
institution is put on the line if
resolution put forward by the ga spins
factual information
the resolution adapted today was leaning
very close towards this direction
Mr President
we must continue to work towards a world
where aggression and violence have no
place and where the principles of
international law and human rights are
respected
we must not apply double standards in
addressing situation of conflicts in all
parts of the world
whether that is the war in Ukraine
in Palestine or any other part of the
world
Indonesia stands ready to support all
efforts towards peace and stability and
we call on the International Community
to do so I thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Indonesia now I offer the floor to
the distinguished representative of
lesser two
[Music]
Mr President the suit was taking the
flaw in expression of position after the
adoption of ISS resolution a stroke es
slash 11 L7 entitled un Charter
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
we must always remember that we came
together under the United Nations as
peace loving states which accept the
obligations contained in the U.N Charter
in the Judgment of the organization are
able to are able
and willing to carry out these
obligations
on everything we do persuadance of
international peace and stability should
be our goal
needless to mention that Article 2
subsection 3 enjoins all member states
to settle their international disputes
by peaceful means in such a manner that
International Peace and security and
Justice are not endangered
it is on this premise that leso today
it's effects itself from Preamble
paragraph 7 and operative paragraph five
the resolution clearly states the
principles to be flawed
to achieve comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine however the
conflict in Ukraine shows no signs of
abating
the Soto family believes that respect
for sovereignty territorial integrity
and political Independence are as
unsrenched as enshrined in the United
Nations Charter as a Christian
principles and should be respected and
upheld by all member states at all times
for the attainment of sustainable
International Peace
was made motivated by genuine desire for
peace
the situation in green raises serious
concerns with political economic and
security ramifications
for Europe and the rest of the world
the manner in which the resolution is
framed further creates distance between
war and practice and does not indicate
any immediate steps for diplomatic
Solutions as well as Endeavors that
would hasten a peaceful settlement of
the conflict
allow me to conclude Mr President by
retreating that Lesotho would like to
see the International Community
constructively supporting parties in the
search for sustainable peace I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Lesotho now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of India
Mr President
India continues to remain concerned over
the situation in Ukraine the conflict
has resulted in the loss of countless
lives and misery particularly for women
children and the elderly with Millions
becoming homeless and forced to seek
shelter in neighboring countries
reports of attacks on civilians and
civilian infrastructure are also deeply
concerning
we have consistently advocated that no
solution can ever be arrived at the cost
of human lives in this context our prime
minister statement that this cannot be
an era of war base repetition
escalation of hostilities and violence
is in no one's interest instead an
urgent return to the path of dialogue
and diplomacy is the way forward
the president India's approach to the
Ukraine conflict will continue to be
people-centric we are providing both
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine and
economic support to some of our
neighbors in the global South under
economic distress even as they stare at
the escalating costs of food of fuel and
fertilizers which has been a
consequential Fallout of the ongoing
conflict
Mr President the overall objective of
today's resolution seeking a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
line with the UN Charter is
understandable
we also note the emphasis on increasing
support by member states for diplomatic
efforts to achieve peace as well as
support for the secretary-general's
efforts to promote a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine however
reports from the ground portray a
complex scenario with the conflict
intensifying on several fronts
today as the general assembly marks a
year of the Ukrainian conflict it is
important that we ask ourselves a few
pertinent questions
are we anywhere near a possible solution
acceptable to both sides
can any process that does not involve
either of the two sides ever lead to a
credible and meaningful solution
has the UN system and particularly its
principal organ the U.N security Council
based on a 1945 World construct not been
rendered ineffective
to address contemporary challenges to
Global Peace and security
Mr President India remains steadfastly
committed to multilateralism and upholds
the principles of the UN Charter we will
always call for dialogue and diplomacy
as the only viable way out while we take
note of the stated objectives of today's
resolution given its inherent
limitations in reaching our desired goal
of securing lasting peace
we are constrained to abstain thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of India
now I give the flow to the
representative of Pakistan
no thank you Mr President
this President Pakistan has abstained
on the Block's resolution contained in
document a stroke es11 stroke L7
I wish to explain the reasons for our
vote
Pakistan is deeply concerned by the
conflict in Ukraine which has caused and
is causing immense human suffering in
Ukraine
and massive damage to its infrastructure
economy and Society
we acknowledge the considerable effort
made by the co-sponsors
to moderate the tone and language of the
draft resolution
Pakistan fully supports the resolutions
call for respect for the principle of
the sovereignty
Sovereign equality and territorial
Integrity of states
and non-acquisition of territory by the
threat or use of force
States cannot be torn apart by the use
of force
Pakistan regrets
that these principles
have not been universally applied and
respected
for instance in the situation of foreign
occupation and the ongoing attempt at
the illegal and forcible annexation of
Jammu and Kashmir
Pakistan also endorses the resolutions
call on member states and international
organizations
to redouble their support for diplomatic
efforts to achieve a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
while the hostilities continue
there is an ever-present danger of a
further military and geographical
escalation of the war
there is thus an imminent threat to
Global Peace and security
Mr President while my delegation agrees
with and endorses the principles and
general Provisions contained in the
draft resolution
there are some Provisions which are not
consistent with Pakistan's principled
position on some of the elements covered
in the resolution
as a country that has seen and suffered
the consequences of prolonged conflict
in our neighborhood
we attach highest priority to the
immediate cessation of hostilities
and the resumption of a dialogue to
achieve a just and durable solution
through direct or indirect negotiations
mediation or other peaceful means
in this regard we see an important role
for the United Nations and the Secretary
General
interrelia under chapter 6 and 8 of the
U.N Charter
for efforts aimed at de-escalation
renewed negotiations and sustained
dialogue for a peaceful diplomatic
solution
Mr President consistent with our
position on the draft resolution in
document Ace stroke es 11 stroke L7 we
have also abstained on the Amendments
proposed to the resolution by Belarus in
documents a stock es11 stroke L8 and a
stroke es11 stroke L9
Mr President Pakistan continues to hope
that in a constructive approach the
parties will soon accept a mutual and
early cessation of hostilities
we also hope for the resumption of a
dialogue for Europe for a durable
resolution of the conflict
based on the principles of the U.N
Charter and past agreements and bearing
in mind the legitimate security
interests of all states I thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Pakistan
distinguished delegates We Have Heard
the Last speaker in exponential vote
after vote
in exercise of the right of replying
has been requested
may I remind members that statements in
the exercise of the right of reply are
limited to 10 minutes for the first
intervention and to five minutes for the
second intervention and should be made
by delegations from their seats
I call on the representative of the
democratic People's Republic of Korea
thank you Mr chair
Mr President my delegation text or flow
to exercise the right of reply in
response to the provocative statement
made by South Korea yesterday
we categorically rejected South Korea's
outrageous Outpost which merits no
comment however now that the South Korea
provoked us let me make a few worse
we reiterate that we have never
recognized the unlawful U.S Security
Council sanctions resolution against the
dprk which was cooked up by the United
States and its a vessel forces
we once again make clear that we have
never had any arms dealings with Russia
and that we have no plan to do so in the
future either
South Korea's Reckless remark is
intolerable as it is totally aimed at
trying to tarnish the image of the dprk
by fabricating on non-existent stuff it
is also a grave provocation that
triggers contraction
clearly speaking at the United States
not infringed upon the Justice security
interests of Russia and accelerated the
Eastward advance of NATO step by step
the present situation of Ukraine would
not have been created
at the present the U.S and other Western
countries are wrecking the global peace
and the regional security while handing
over military hardware to Ukraine to the
value of an astronomical sum of money in
total disregard of Russia's security
concerns
we'd like to draw the attention of the
member stage to the fact that in January
the NATO Secretary General flew to South
Korea to put pressure on the latter for
its passive Military Support to Ukraine
it is also an Open Secret that South
Korea is seeking to supply ammunitions
and weaponry to Ukraine in the face of
the mounting pressure from the United
States
it is a matter of time that military
hardware of South Korea will turn up in
the battlefields in Ukraine
South Korea's allegation is aimed at
distracting the attention of the
International Community from its
criminal record
we have already made clear that we will
not deal with the South Korea
South Korea should be well aware that if
he continues to provoke costs
groundlessly it will face extreme
security crisis far from diffusing as a
security aniteness
taking this opportunity we stress that
the previous two Russian people
have to build and capability to defend
the security and territorial Integrity
of the country without any outside
Military Support I thank you Mr
President
I call on the represent
of India
thank you Mr President
Mr President I am taking the floor today
to say that India chooses this time not
to respond to Pakistan's mischievous
provocations Our advice to the delegate
of Pakistan is to refer to our numerous
rights of reply that we have exercised
in the past
Pakistan has only to look at itself and
its own track record as a state that
harbors and provides safe havens to
terrorists and does so with impunity
such uncalled for provocation is
particularly regrettable and certainly
misplaced at a time when after two days
of intense discussions we have all
agreed that the part of Peace can be the
only path forward to resolve conflict
and Discord I thank you
thank you
I call on the representative of Pakistan
thank you Mr President for giving me the
floor
an exercise of my right of reply we
would like to make the following points
India continues to perpetrate a
factually incorrect position on this
forum year after year
Jammu and Kashmir is an internationally
recognized disputed territory and not an
integral part of India as it has been
claimed
repeating a wrong position would not
make it acceptable at any point the
focus of today's debate is on people
another crisis that we face at hand and
one of the alienable rights of the
people enshrined in the very first
article of the charter is the right of
self-determination
in the case of kashmiri people the right
to self-determination has been
recognized and promised to them by the
U.N security Council through its
resolutions
for over seven decades India has
prevented the kashmiris through force
and fraud from exercising this right and
holding the U.N supervised plebiscite to
enable the kashmiris to determine their
destiny
India has imprisoned the entire kashmiri
leadership illegally detained thousands
of kashmiri youths including women and
children similarly executed young boys
put down protests violently and burnt
down entire neighborhoods and villages
Indian illegally occupied Jammu and
Kashmir Remains the most militarized
Zone in the world very close to 900 000
security forces have been deployed by
India to curb the legitimate struggle of
the kashmiri people
but such measures only serve to
intensify the struggle of the people of
Jammu and Kashmir for the right to serve
determination even in the face of worst
atrocities as evident from thousands of
unknown unmarked Mass graves in Indian
illegally occupied Jammu and Kashmir the
innocent people of Jammu and Kashmir
remain firm in their claim for their
right to serve determination Pakistan
will keep exposing Indian brutalities
and inform the International Community
of the plight of the kashmiri people I
thank you Mr President
thank you
I call on the representative of the
Republic of Korea
thank you Mr President my delegation
applied for a light of reply to make a
few commands about DPI case remarks
let me be short but very clear
We Believe each statement distracted our
very reason why all of us are here
together
it is about our desire for international
peace and stability it is about our
respect for justice and international
law
and it is about our commitment to the
core principles and values of the United
United Nations Charter
my delegation believes all the
representatives here know who is
violating its duties under the U.N
Charter and international law
needless to say it is tprk
we also like to truly affirm that any
Arts trade without eprk constitutes a
blatant violation of the U.N security
Council resolutions I thank you Mr
President
thank you
I call on the representative of the
democratic People's Republic of Korea
for the second intervention
thank you Mr President for giving it a
floral gain my delegation is compared to
take the flow to exercise the second
order of the right right of reply in
response to the
statement by South Korea we are not
going to reiterate our position but we
take these opportunities to strongly
condemn South Korea's attempt to Insight
and frequently cider confrontation in
this August forum and we condemning the
strongest terms that the Security
Council is being transformed into a tool
for implementing the Hostile policy of
the United States and South Korea and
other vessel forces without mentioning a
single word about the United States and
South Korea join military exercises now
taking place in and around the Korean
Peninsula which is seriously encroached
upon the security interests of the dprk
we seriously want South Korea that if it
continues to come up with the business
accusations in Hot Pursuit Of yes or
hostile policy against the dprk it will
inevitably face Greatest Secret disaster
South Korea must appear in mind that
continued submission to the United
States will lead to the self-destruction
I thank you Mr President
thank you
in accordance with the terms of
paragraph 11 of the resolution just
adopted the 11th emergency special
session of the general assembly is
temporary adjourned this meeting is
adjourned
foreign